I was giving Henry's speech at Asian
core of about three minutes ago we few
we marry a few we Band of Brothers and
Sisters it's updated and uh all of a
in seven years
except on the floor of the house so
opening the hearing of Tuesday May 23rd
on the special committee on the Family
Division of the Circuit Court of
appointments are the ones who are here
and
all I'm going to read by way of
introduction you all know that there
have been several iterations of this
kind of committee and we've heard that
so I just have to read the notice and
disclaimer the special committee on the
Family Division of the Circuit Court was
formed to investigate allegations of
irregularities including failure to
follow or enforce statutes
unwarranted waiver of or failure to
follow court rules delay in rendering
decisions denial of due process and
other procedural issues the committee
will conduct hearings relative to the
process of the Family Division of the
circuit court and may make
recommendations for future legislation
the purpose of the committee is to
discover areas where changes in
procedures or changes in law regarding
the Family Division of the Circuit Court
might be made the purpose of this
special committee is not to retry cases
of citizens who disagree with the
outcome of litigation
members of the public will be given
opportunity to testify and present
information to the committee because of
the number of people who may wish to
testify there may be a time limit
imposed on each person testifying which
is permissible under house rule 100.
appropriate subject matter for
testifying will be limited to specific
instances of where there seem to be
irregularities in process procedure or
adherence to rules and statutes
and I want to emphasize that if you come
up here and talk in generalities it is
not helpful to us you will not influence
us because you've not given us anything
to consider make it specific to a case
and the specific problem you had with
those testifying about subject matter
related to a court case or who submit
documentation related to a court case
should know that both will be made part
of the public record
therefore subject matter that is either
confidential or maybe under seal should
not be discussed or submitted to the
committee as disclosure of such matters
would be a violation of Statute or of a
court order
and the committee reserves the right not
to accept written or oral testimony or
materials which would in its judgment
violate the foregoing
and with that our valued committee
researcher who is up first to make a
the New Hampshire Court Improvement I
thought we were the New Hampshire Court
good morning
good morning chairman person good to see
you so my name is Susan Ashley I'm the
deputy administrative judge for the
Circuit Court here in New Hampshire and
I am here today to assist on discussing
the court Improvement project but first
and foremost I would like to introduce
you all to Christy Lamont she has been
working for the court Improvement
project here in New Hampshire for
27 years she started when she was 12.
um but quite a long time and she is most
certainly the expert on the court
Improvement project so I will let her
have the floor
good morning I really appreciate the
chance to be here and what I'd like to
do is provide a brief overview of the
New Hampshire Court Improvement project
and then judge Ashley is going to
describe one of our more recent
initiatives related to permanency
hearings
so in terms of the Court Improvement
project we are a hundred percent
federally funded
our funding comes through the U.S
Department of Health and Human Services
the administration for Children and
Families
and as a Federal Grant I have a federal
representative in Boston with whom I
work closely he and I together work on
federal requirements for the court
Improvement project what the national
initiatives are that Court Improvement
projects are encouraged to consider and
also he's available to answer any
questions or address any concerns I may
have
all states have received Court
Improvement project funds and have
created their own Court Improvement
projects so New Hampshire is part of
this national movement that began in
1994.
nationally the purpose of the Court
Improvement project is to improve child
welfare outcomes and there are three
parts to that and I'd like to share
those parts with you and also talk to
you about how New Hampshire has
responded to those parts
so the first part is collaboration
between the judicial branch and the
child agency and as applicable tribes
and in New Hampshire beginning in 1994
when the court Improvement project funds
were accepted in New Hampshire
collaboration for us has been one of our
strengths there's a very very strong
collaboration between the court system
dcyf we've expanded that to all
stakeholders in child protection matters
so that includes the Attorney General's
office Casa of New Hampshire the
judicial Council Office of child
advocate dcyf and also parent attorneys
so all of our work that we do as
multi-disciplinary and those groups are
again National purpose to improve child
welfare outcomes the way we do that in
New Hampshire primarily has been around
Court protocols developing Court
protocols
and I'd like you to refer to the second
handout
so we're developing core protocols
really
with a goal of consistent practice in
the circuit courts throughout the state
consistent practice procedures process
that's the goal of the Court Improvement
and also of our protocols
and when we talk about court protocols
what by that what we mean is we've
developed a document that includes
federal law state law New Hampshire
Supreme Court cases and also nationally
best practices so anytime we refer to to
court protocols that's what we're
referring to all of that work we're
that second handout that we gave you
that's a picture of our what's on the
judicial Branch's website related to
abuse neglect cases and you can see
there we've developed a number of
protocols I know it's small but if you
go to the judicial Branch's website for
abuse neglect cases this is what you'll
see
we also included on the website links to
trainings that we've developed when we
develop protocols we often develop a a
video training just because there's so
much turnover for all the stakeholders
so these training videos are available
they're between 6 minutes and 50 minutes
but they're a great introduction high
level overview of the protocols that
I just want to highlight a couple of the
protocols on that second handout the
first one is protocols relative to abuse
neglect cases and that's really the
foundation of our work excuse me what
does this look like I'm drowning in
paper the second handout the culture
thank you yeah absolutely
so the process protocols yeah yes yep
that's that's okay
um so the protocol is relative to abuse
neglect cases that's work that we began
in the late 1990s we rolled it out in
2000 and it's a actually I have it for
you
this is what it is these are our court
protocols the initial effort of the the
court Improvement project there's a
chapter dedicated to each hearing type
and abuse neglect cases and it's really
the first guidance that we've had in New
Hampshire for all of the stakeholders as
they prepare for court hearings and it's
also guidance for the courts for judges
so that they again consistent Court
practice we want consistent core
practice throughout the circuit courts
in New Hampshire and so this guides them
in that regard
the last at the bottom of that page it
says 2012 protocols relative to Children
and Youth in court
that's an example of a national
initiative to encourage children in
court to come to the court hearings
we've heard nationally that kids want to
be part of the process they very much
want to meet the judge have an
opportunity to come into court it's it's
their option they're not required to do
it if they'd like to do it they're able
to come and so we develop protocols to
set out what that would look like how
kids would be invited to court when they
came to court what that process would
look like so those are our children and
youth in court protocols
the third handout I'd like to refer can
we stop on that handout and see if
who inputted
to you for this document who'd you talk
with
so again multi-disciplinary committee so
we had courts input from courts from
dcyf from parent attorneys from the
judicial Council from DC I think I said
dcyf
and Casa of New Hampshire
so as we develop them the way it works
is we have multi-disciplinary committees
that develop these protocols and it's
not only the group that's convened but
we really encourage folks to take back
to their stakeholder group questions
concerns drafts of protocols and then we
came together to finalize the protocols
I didn't hear
an individual
appearing Pro Se some of them to input
because their experiences we've learned
can be somewhat different sure
absolutely sure
um so just to clarify the cases that the
court Improvement project is focusing on
are our abuse and neglect cases okay and
so while we have many many
self-represented litigants in divorce
and parenting cases domestic violence
cases all of those types of things and
our abuse and neglect cases in New
Hampshire
almost everybody has attorney
representation
of course the agency has attorney
representation but the parents by and
large have attorney representation
except if they're a non-petitioned
parent so the statutes in New Hampshire
do not allow the court to appoint an
attorney for non-petitioned parent
unless they are a household member and
so there are some folks who do not have
counsel and they would be those few
self-represented folks who are coming to
the abuse and neglect cases but all of
the petitioned parents everyone who was
petitioned with an abuse or neglect case
they have the right to court appointed
counsel Madam Vice chair
and what's a petition here thank you for
that question
um so if the division for children youth
and families after doing an assessment
in an investigation believe that they
need to bring a court case to address
the abuse or neglect in other words they
don't believe that they can assist fully
with protection of that child
outside of the court process then they
will file a petition with the court
essentially asserting that the mother
and or the father or both have neglected
the child and they'll explain how or
have abused the child and they'll
explain how in that petition it is not a
criminal case
you see these are civil matters so they
are petitioned into court for whatever
that case is in and sometimes it is both
abuse and neglect so one case can have
representative long
thank you Mr chairman uh just uh for
clarification
um in references Children and Youth
abuse and neglect uh are youth 16
consistently 16 and older and children
are 15 below
um we don't really necessarily Define
what's a youth and what's a child when
we talk about children and youth it's
just that sometimes we recognize that
the 17 year olds don't like to be called
children so we might use that broader
phrase of Youth but there's no specific
definition there are certain
laws that do specify what we can order
for a permanency hearing for instance
for someone who is of a certain age and
but other than that there isn't a
specific definition of child or youth
okay and a follow-up for me follow up
thank you uh
I saw a reference 16
um 16 year olds
um so are some statute or or some of the
understanding that a youth will be 16.
um Let me let me answer that I think
I've got a a clearer answer than what I
gave before
in a case when it when we get to the
point after a parent is petitioned and a
finding is made of abuse or neglect then
and the child or youth Israel has been
removed from parents care
generally speaking there's some
asterisks to that but generally speaking
the parents have 12 months to resolve
the issues and hopefully reunify if we
get to that point and we're having a
permanency hearing then if the parents
haven't satisfied the statutory grounds
to have that child return to them then
the court has to select a different
permanency plan than reunification
there is one permanency plan there's
only a couple of options adoption
through termination or Surrender
parental rights guardianship
or what we call Apple another planned
permanent living Arrangement which is a
mouthful but afla by federal law can
only be ordered for a youth who is 16 or
older so that's where you're seeing the
16 reference and we have a small number
in New Hampshire who fit into that
category and so we often refer to them
as our Apple youth very good thank you
any other questions from anybody
uh yes way down the end there thank you
and thank you for taking my question I
just want to clarify about the protocols
um I think that it was um the first
Witnesses said they're based on federal
law case law statutes and best practices
so is there really these are a road map
for everyone attorneys in Pro Se so
there's not really a lot of public input
into these These are kind of uh
objective
points that need to be hit correct yes
that's correct and I would just add to
that to the extent dcyf has parents with
with lived experience they would bring
that feedback to us that's how we would
would get that information from parents
thank you
you may continue great
so the third handout and and this fits
very nicely the third handout is in
addition to developing protocols the
next step for us is to say are there
core forms that we need to develop to
support the protocols support state law
federal law and so we often develop
forms we develop standard court orders
again consistent practice is the goal
for us and so I've included the notice
that goes out to a petition parent so a
parent against who yes that's the one we
also have two other forms very similar
to this one for a non-petition parent
who's a household member so that
non-petition parent living with with the
petition parent and as judge Ashley said
that non-petition parent the court has
the discretion to appoint that
non-petition parent an attorney in the
abuse neglect case and the protocol is
strongly strongly recommend that the
courts exercise their discretion and
appoint that non-petition parent and
attorney
so this is a great form this is another
roadmap this is the form that a petition
parent would receive and again a
non-petition parent who's a household
member gets a separate form and then we
have a third form very similar for a
non-petition non-household parent and it
walks them through the process very very
well section two is their financial
responsibility that's on page one
section three again this is a petition
parent indicating you have a court of
you have a right to a court appointed
attorney
Roman 4 is telling that petition parent
that your child is going to be appointed
a guardian ad litem in this case and
then on the back page
section five is is a request giving this
petition parent information about a
request that a non-petition parent could
make and that request is that if we have
a non-petition parent in an abuse or
neglect case that parent is able to say
I'd like my child to be placed with me
and if there's an objection to that by
dcyf what that results in is the court
scheduling what's called a parental
Fitness hearing and at that parental
Fitness hearing the judge is going to
decide if that non-petition parent is
fit or unfit if the court finds that the
position the non-petition parent is fit
then their child is going to be placed
with them
section six this question sure so far
was that your hand or not okay
um under the ad litem I was under the
impression that the uh parents in
question uh have to pay for the guardian
ad litem or is that only in divorce
cases
so yeah this is the guardian ad litem
for their child
but you're yes in abuse and neglect
cases again very different from the
divorce parenting Arena and every abuse
and neglect case the court is required
to appoint Casa a casa volunteer as the
guardian ad Liden for the child so there
is never a cost to the parents to answer
your question there's never a cost to
the parents for a guardian Adeline in an
abuse and neglect case that is very
different from a divorce parenting we
have to appoint Casa if there's Co if
there is a casa volunteer available
um sometimes they do not have enough
volunteers available then we would point
a point what we refer to as a private
Guardian Ad Litem in other words a
non-costa guardian ad litem and um and
the judicial Council pays for the cost
of that Guardian Ad Litem in the abuse
and neglect case
okay
so then Romans section 6 is an
explanation of the Court hearings in the
process and this is this is information
that we The Hope here is that the
parents the parent will have an attorney
and that their attorney will review this
form with them with with special
attention to the court process what is
going to happen at each hearing type and
then on the last page it lets parents
know again petition's been filed this is
an overview of the court process the
last page lets them know that if that
they're going to have this opportunity
to correct service is going to be
provided by dcyf and they're and if they
don't correct the conditions that led to
the Court's finding that's assuming that
the court makes a finding of abuse and
neglect then the division May file a
petition to terminate their parental
rights so they're told all of this
information at the very beginning of
that abuse and neglect case
how far ahead of time
are they told
when the petition is filed okay right
away and they're served uh with the
petition that's sort of the beginning of
the case when they're served with that
the emergency order if there is one but
then with the petition this form goes
with that service packet so they'll have
that as soon as they get any information
about the case but then as Christy was
indicating at the first hearing when
they talk with their attorney they'll be
reviewing it with them and then the
court reviews this information with them
on the record at the first hearing so
there's several opportunities for them
to understand they served in the same
way a process server would serve any
process anything
the um the police departments serve
these petitions as opposed to the
Sheriff's Department generally speaking
you know in New Hampshire that is the
way because it they're in touch with the
situation a little bit more carefully so
that's the local law enforcement is who
receives this information and then they
bring it to the parents what if the
person
refuses to take the packet
then their law enforcement would reflect
that they left the the packet with them
and they would let us know that so that
their feet consider the job complete and
walk away well I I don't know because I
don't do the service but again these
aren't criminal cases so there wouldn't
be an arrest of that parent right it's
their child that there's an allegation
who's been abused or neglected we want
to have the parents involved because
ultimately we want there to be
permanency for the child make sure the
child is safe and then make sure that we
are achieving permanency so it's
important to have the parents involved
and they may not initially choose to be
involved but we will continue to make
efforts the court is making those
efforts the agency dcyf must make those
efforts to continue to get that parent
all parents involved so there's a
presumption that they'll probably
receive the packet when it's offered to
them but in case not there is a very
immediate way to say we have done
diligence on this they are without
excuse yes thank you
representative kadab
thank you chairman Pearson and thank you
judge Ashley for taking my question so I
just so I'm understanding correctly for
there to be a finding of abuse and
neglect would this be done
through a judge or are you saying when
dcyf may have a finding of I just want
to understand at what point there's
actually a finding if it's through a
court hearing and then this 12-month
clock sticks after the court hearing or
if it's through dcyf it is uh so I am
referring to cases that are filed with
the court so when dcyf files a petition
with the court then the court will
ultimate the first hearing is that
preliminary hearing but then we'll be
scheduling the adjudicatory hearing
which is as I tell the parents this is
the trial on the actual merits of the
petition and if the court finds abuse or
finds neglect at that point in time
that's really when the clock starts
ticking because it's by Statute by New
Hampshire statute it's 12 months from
that adjudication date that when that
order goes out except if
there's a request for an early
permanency hearing there's always the
asterisk so there's now statutory
exception we might have time to get into
representative long
thank you Mr chairman uh I see this form
was uh January 1st of 22 with a forms
prior to this and how often would you
upgrade to when you hear of problems
with parents trying to understand it
we're always
we're always revising uh this form was
not initially made available in 2020
this is just the 2020 version is just
the most recent version
so and it's a great question anytime we
develop protocols judge Ashley and I
revisit prior court forms court orders
and say what do we need to update where
do we need to update it we also do that
based on feedback we get just just
anecdotally we're always soliciting
feedback from our multi-disciplinary
group and from the folks they hear from
to say bring us information
and we we spend a lot of time updating
forms and quarter court orders great
representative Lanza
thank you um chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um do you have these forms in different
languages as well
um because I know many
many people within uh New Hampshire are
from different backgrounds and stuff and
have
we do not
um that's a the issue of forms is an
area that we are continuing to try to
improve upon as far as what we have for
availability and what our techno
technological capabilities are
um but any any forms that of course are
filed with the court or the court orders
have to actually be in English so we
those are sort of our standard forms
have to be in English we would like to
have the ability to have them translated
into other languages but at this point
they're all in English and and they're
generally all on our website again the
link that the doc that first document
about
um the you know that lists all of the
protocols is one page of the Court's
website there are other links on the
website that do include the court forms
so you can kind of go through those and
look at those forms if you'd like to as
well
follow up
just another another question do you
have translators available within your
court system for these people that do
not only speak English yes we do thank
you for that question
um anyone who needs translation services
of course for any court hearing would be
provided that and then if there's anyone
who needs that Beyond either if they're
up at the window we have the ability to
contact someone who can translate for
them and assist in that capacity
thank you
you may continue great thank you
the other form that we included is um
it's called dcyf's affidavit to identify
and or locate a parent guardian or
putative father
so that should be behind
the notice form
As you move through the packet it looks
like this
okay
so we wanted to share this one with you
because a significant emphasis of the
Court Improvement project has been
around missing parents
and by that we mean when a petition is
filed against a parent
we may have a second parent who is
unknown their name we may have their
name we may not have their address we
may not have a name
so the ongoing obligation of dcyf is to
continue to look to identify and or
located that missing parent and so as we
developed protocols we also developed
this affidavit and it's it's an
affidavit that comes into the judge for
before every court hearing at which
there's a case involving a missing
parent
it's a significant significant issue not
to have both parents involved engaged at
the beginning of the case so this is a
great example of collaboration between
the court system and the ndcyf we have
protocols we develop protocols on
missing parents what needs to happen
when there's a missing parent and then
what does happen once that missing
parent is identified and located the
importance of getting that parent served
and engaged bringing that parent into
the cases into the case and into court
hearings
so this is a great example of we develop
missing parent protocols and then we
said how do we support those and we said
let's develop an affidavit and this
affidavit was
developed after extensive research of
what other states are doing around
affidavits what are other states doing
when there's a missing parent and an
abuse or neglect case we don't want that
missing we don't want that case to just
continue without ongoing efforts by the
division to identify locate that parent
so this is the affidavit that comes into
the court before every court hearing
with a missing parent gives the court an
opportunity to know what is the division
doing what has the division done between
the last hearing and this current
hearing and then an opportunity for the
court to engage dcyf and a colloquy
around the importance of those ongoing
efforts and what they should look like
between the current hearing and the next
hearing again huge huge significance so
important to get both parents identified
engaged and involved in these hearings
uh representative catab
I see that this form
um
thank you Mr chairman
um thank you for taking my question I
see that this forum was created in 2020
was there a form prior to that for this
or did it just start did this um
initiative just start in 2020 I just
want to understand when the initiative
started great question
um this is not the first form this form
actually began as a dcyf form
and when we when we developed the
missing protocols we said we want we
wanted to revisit that form and revise
it improve it and make it a court form
and the Court's expectation is that this
form is going to come in before every
you may continue great
so the other thing we do we develop
protocols we develop court orders forms
the other thing we do is try to evaluate
our efforts and so we've shared with you
today some survey results and this goes
to the protocols that we developed
coming back to the 16 year old youth
so for a 16 year old youth with apla as
their permanency plan
parents were were not able to meet the
standard for their youth to be returned
home
adoption is not an appropriate
permanency plan for for that youth a
guardianship isn't a pro is not an
appropriate permanency plan for that
youth so we have apla another planned
permanent living Arrangement and what
our protocol is set out for is that when
when the courts have an apple Youth and
at this time there are about 30 of them
in the state so a very small universe
but a universe of Youth at significant
risk and we know that these are young
people at risk for homelessness
pregnancy prison substance misuse so as
much as it's a small Universe of Youth
it's a it's a group at high high risk
and so our response to that was to
develop protocols and those are the
protocols on the Court's website they're
called protocols relative to post
permanency hearings for Apple youth
and it's it's a shift for the court what
we set out in the protocols we want the
courts to have a more informal hearing
we want to shift away from the parties
reporting to the courts about the status
of the case and we want it to become a
discussion really between the judge and
the youth
again these are young people they're 16
17 18. they could be out on their own in
a very short time and so what we
developed with these protocols we said
we want to help these young people to
create some to develop some life skills
and so we want them to come to court we
want them to talk to the judge we want
them to take responsibility for their
life what's what it's going to look like
at the end of this case when this case
closes and all of these folks are no
longer in their life
so those are the protocols we've
developed and then we said we want to
know how we're doing have have these
protocols achieved one of the outcomes
for us and one of those outcomes is that
these young people not only come to
court but they have a positive
experience in coming to court and they
come back that we want them to come back
so these there's a survey that they can
do online it's I believe 17 questions
short should take them about five
minutes they can do it online if they do
it they get a gift card because we're
trying to incentivize them to complete
this and let us know about their
experience in court
and so we've just given you some of the
results from the question about did you
feel today's court hearing was a
positive experience and why and as you
see there almost 80 percent of them had
a positive experience
and then the other question is do you
plan to come back do you come plan to
come back and almost like 96 of them
said they want to come back and as you
look at these comments you'll see that
it does reflect that they're having a
positive experience coming to court
they're wanting to advocate for
themselves they recognize the importance
of being part of the process and
planning for their future
um so anyway this is again an example of
what we do when we create protocols it's
not only creating the protocols but it's
some effort to find out how have we done
I'd be curious to know what the other
questions
are you said there were 17 questions
sure and the survey is online so that
um again on the web page the survey you
can access online general questions how
old are you was it an in-person or
remote hearing who was the judge you saw
today is this is it the same judge
you've seen in the past which court were
you in questions like that
if I could follow up
um
so then there isn't a question that says
did you feel today's court hearing was a
negative experience
there's not but
there is not and um is there a question
that asks do you have any suggestions
about ways that this could be improved
our final question is an opportunity for
them to provide any comments they have
when your testimony is finished and you
give us a survey as to how we think you
did what's the gift card we get
I would have settled for less but I
but it's better than nothing I do have a
question
um for
um
Deputy administrative judge Ashley
reports like this feedback forms like
this might this be profitably extended
yes
um I know that was a push question it
was leading the witness
um it is we're very fortunate of course
to have the funding that we do have for
the court Improvement project for this
narrow niche of cases that we handle in
the circuit court for abuse and neglect
cases
um there are efforts that are made to
see what we have available for other
resources that would allow us to have
this similar not necessarily this type
of a survey because this is very
specific to these youth but to have more
General survey for court users because
we think that we can get a lot of input
from that because it seems like now with
my I was going to say my research but my
research assistance research that we're
like now the fifth group that's whacking
at this in 20 years
um it could be wisely a wise investment
of money for more forms for more aspects
of circuit court
so that this could be an ongoing process
and not something we have to assemble
every five years or so and there may be
more information about this later but
there's a pilot project right now for a
similar survey if you will and we're
really hoping to utilize the pilot
nature of this that's happening right
now to see how receptive folks are to
giving that feedback in other words how
many actually participated in the survey
and that kind of information to see if
we can then translate that in a broader
pilot project that's in one of the rural
up counties that had a year of
conceptualization and has been actually
functioning for about three or four
months now
um the well the pilot that I am thinking
of is the pilot that's going on in in
Brentwood with their some kiosks and and
there's some technology going on there
um there was a there was a grant that
was available to Institute that uh or
some Grant funds and so we are hopeful
that the report after that process is
instructive not only for the results
that came back but but the actual
process itself of trying to get the
feedback in other words was that a good
way to do so sort of folks who are there
in the courthouse it's not the actually
the pilot project I was thinking of do
you know the one I was thinking of
up count up country somewhere in small
County and well we've got a few Pilots
going on and so maybe that's an issue
that we can touch base on the next time
we come back in could well be thank you
thank you
representative ball
thank you chairman Pearson just for
justification
um
the
this uh questionnaire this is just for
the children is there another one that's
for the parents who um were involved in
the same court
it's just a survey for youth with apple
as their permanency plan okay so 16 plus
but you are just a follow-up
um but you're just said that you are
thinking about doing it also for the
parents to see is did I understand that
correctly
what I was really referring to with
Sharon Pearson is whether or not generic
surveys are helpful in getting feedback
on all case types for the court so at
this point there is an initiative to
have a survey for cases for parents in
the abuse and neglect field but we could
certainly consider that
um to see if that is something that
would be helpful likely we would talk
with the parent attorneys to see if they
think that that is something that would
be a good initiative
because the Federal grant to fund this
committee hasn't come through not quite
you may continue great
so what I'd like to turn to now is part
three of the national purpose of
improving child welfare outcomes and
that is for court Improvement projects
including ours to support legal
representation for parents for Children
and Youth and also for the child welfare
agency that's the one
so it's the it says National Association
of council for children at the top
so what we've done in New Hampshire what
I'd like to focus on is our our
efforts to support parent attorneys
parent attorneys appointed in abuse
neglect cases to represent parents and
we're really really pleased to be doing
this work parent attorneys it's an
important stakeholder group for us it's
it's a challenge because unlike
the public defender the this group of
attorneys there isn't a public defender
like organization that oversees parent
attorneys in 169 C cases so a lot of
these folks are Solo practitioners my
understanding from from working with the
judicial council is there about 70 plus
parent attorneys for 169 C cases about
70 plus
not enough there's a there's a shortage
of attorneys taking these cases and so
what we said we as a group again a
multi-disciplinary group coming together
to say how can we support this really
important stakeholder group and what we
decided to do was
um two things the first seems
it's taken a long time but we we have a
list serve now we've the court
Improvement project has helped to
develop a listserv that's available for
parent attorneys we felt that that would
be a valuable resource for them a
community for parent attorneys place for
them to ask questions concerns and so
what we're doing on the court
Improvement project side is we're using
our our some of our resources our funds
to pay an attorney a stipend a New
Hampshire attorney to facilitate that
listserv we don't want to be part of
that it needs to be confidential to
parent attorneys but we we made it so
that we brought it to New Hampshire
we're paying an attorney so that she'll
facilitate it the other thing she's
doing is bringing back to us any themes
that she sees as part of that listserv
so again that's an opportunity for input
from parent attorneys we also hope from
their their clients parents but we very
much want her to bring back not case
specific no case specific information
but just the themes what are the issues
the systemic issues that as that we
could possibly address
so that's the first thing we've done for
parent attorneys the second thing is we
have contracted with the National
Association of council for children for
that group to develop a two-day
eight-hour New Hampshire specific
training for parent attorneys
my understanding is it's the first of
its kind for parent attorneys we're also
going to make it available to law
students hoping to expose them to abuse
and neglect cases encourage them to go
into this work when they graduate from
Law School
the training is free for law students
free for parent attorneys all of it is
being supported by the court Improvement
project
and I've given you the agenda for that
training it's going to be as I say it's
a two-day commitment so parent attorneys
it's two days two days eight hours of
training and it's October 6th and
December 1. and this is the invitation
that's gone out to parent attorneys
again that Universe of 70 plus parent
attorneys encouraging them to
participate in this two-day training
and if this was designed after again
feedback we we love love to fit solicit
feedback so the court Improvement
project helped to coordinate
brainstorming sessions focus groups with
Circuit Court judges and also parent
attorneys asking them what are the needs
what are the strengths what are the
weaknesses how can we develop a training
that really is not only for new parent
attorneys but also experienced parent
attorneys there's a lot involved in this
work there's federal law is extensive
state law there's just so much to learn
so this is the training that's that's
been developed the other nice thing
about it is there are two New Hampshire
attorneys who are working with the
National Association of council for
children working on the materials for
the training again New Hampshire
specific it's going to be a webinar it's
also going to be available for up I
believe it's a year like so that the
trainings will be offered this year and
then for the next year parent attorneys
are going to be able to access this
training and again we've dedicated
significant CIP resources to this work
because we think it's so critical that
parent attorneys be well prepared you
see there's a section here on day one
adjudication and trial skills that's
something that judges identified as a
need and parent attorneys identified as
a need I think everybody agreed that
that was an area where there was some
room for improvement and so we brought
that to the National Association of
council for children and said this is
what folks in New Hampshire have
identified it's what they said will
really again the goal here is high
quality legal representation for parents
in 169c cases
yes representative Smith please for a
question thank you very much going back
to um
the very first page of this very helpful
uh packet that you gave us
um under two it says Court protocols and
training for judges and RSA 169c
stakeholders
have I missed something I haven't in
this packet seen anything about training
for judges
it's a great question and I what I
should have said we do a lot of
trainings for judges to answer your
question we do a lot of trainings judge
Ashley and I when when judges are
appointed to the bench she and I spend
three days with newly appointed judges
and it's dedicated to abuse and neglect
cases
um part of that training includes Court
observation we spend a morning and
afternoon in court and then we debrief
the other part of the day
um it's it's an extensive training that
we do with judges we also do ongoing
trainings the judges meet every other
month and often abuse and neglect will
be part of the agenda just ongoing our
ongoing work our ongoing efforts and
those trainings go well beyond abuse and
neglect
if follow up
I am pleased in New Hampshire that we do
not elect judges
um I think
we end up with a theoretically a better
quality of Judge than if we went through
an election process
however I wonder if you have given any
thought to
whether can a Judicial candidates have
had any experience in in your particular
Focus abuse and neglect
um I'm in this committee we're
interested in somewhat in that and
another broad category which is
generally the responsibilities of within
the family court
so that we have
candidates for Family Court who have or
so
as part of the Judiciary we don't
actually have input into the selection
of the judges who are nominated and then
confirmed that's really in the executive
branch they and so the governor handles
that
and what we
do when we have a judge who is appointed
to our bench who is we do these
extensive training so as Christie was
saying we will explain all sort of Soup
To Nuts abuse and neglect cases you are
correct that there may be judges who are
coming in who don't have any experience
with abuse and neglect cases at all
that would have been me when I was
actually nominated
um to the bench because I didn't have
the opportunity to be involved in abuse
and neglect cases and it actually isn't
that unusual for our judges to not have
experience because as we've talked about
the people who are involved in these
cases are dcyf so we'll be maybe a dcyf
attorney but other than that on that
side of it we have volunteer Casa of
folks and then we have folks who do this
um parents attorney representation often
sole practitioners those it is very
unusual to have broader attorneys
involved in our abuse and neglect cases
it's kind of an insular field if you
will so it is very common that judges
who are appointed to the Circuit Court
don't actually have much of any
experience maybe they were a private gal
at some point and so they had some some
insight so they're often coming to this
work without much knowledge what
benefits them though is that the
statutes in abuse and neglect are
very extensive so there's clear
statutory guidance from the legislature
as to what sort of the rules of the road
are and then we have extensive protocols
as Christie's been discussing here for
quite some time and those are always
available to the judges and then we will
do the new judge training with them and
then we're there all of the time for
support thereafter so I have learned
from my fellow judges through the years
and now here I am sitting here with
quite a lot of experience in abuse and
neglect cases and I'm the one who's
answering the questions when folks have
questions on the bench but it is an
opportunity for us to continue to
educate our Judiciary on these important
issues so thank you for that question
follow-up
thank you um so you do you've described
extensive
um introductory training the beginning
of the process
are there and we're looking now just at
um
abuse and neglect I understand we're not
looking at the other areas in family
court
is there supervision that's ongoing and
is there accountability that's ongoing
in terms of evaluation
of of the judges
thank you for that question so as as we
mentioned there's the initial training
but then there is ongoing trainings that
we continue to sort of touch upon
issues and abuse and neglect cases and
it may be that we're revisiting certain
protocols certain statutory requirements
because we are getting feedback and we
do get feedback from the stakeholders
that is what is most helpful about the
collaboration that we have in this field
is that we are able to get some input
back about you know broad brush input
back about how things are going in
different parts of the state because
sometimes there are different needs in
different parts of the state resource
needs Etc or doesn't seem like the you
know the the court staff or the judge is
understanding the process maybe there's
someone new it's the security desk and
they're not letting the child in even
though the child's going to actually be
coming to this particular hearing so
there's always the need for that ongoing
Loop the feedback and the revisiting of
the issues and then there is the need to
train on the new issues that arise so
when there's a legislative change for
instance events and sometimes we're
involved with that legislative process
sometimes we are not involved but their
needs to we need to make sure that
everyone understands that there is a
change in the law
and this is how it's going to impact
these particular cases and I know we're
probably well past our time but the last
handout that you have is just
one piece of the information that we
provided to the court when the
permanency statute changed in January of
2022 we provided this handout not just
to our judges but to our court staff to
the dcyf staff and attorneys to Casas
and private gals to parent attorneys to
anyone who who would take a piece of
paper from us really
um but just to folks who needed to
understand that it is complicated the
statute is complicated but it had very
specific and necessary changes that
would lead to better permanency for
children and it was going to change the
process a bit including having that
early permanency hearing that we
probably don't need to go into today but
some significant changes that came out
of a legislative committee and we worked
very hard to educate everybody that we
could on the issues we are out of time
but I do have one final question maybe
there's one or two more representative
gay you want to be in on this on the
second page age of this document
for the Friday December 1st Gathering of
your cohort 1 to 3 P.M this session will
emphasize advocacy for reunification and
representative gay this is an issue that
is important to you so I'm wondering if
it might be valuable for you to touch
base with attorney Lamont at some point
prior to this because we're going to
you're going to go forward with some
things on this I know so just pointing
that out it's in the
um
training that's going to be given to
family lawyers parental lawyers and law
students
well with representative long for the
last question
thank you Mr chairman uh with going back
to uh this training uh 70 plus attorneys
for parents which is not enough
is there any reach out to other states
that have attorneys practice in in this
uh
abuse and neglect for this training or
uh yes and no what I can tell you is the
the two the woman we're working with
from the National Association of council
for children she's done similar
trainings in other states so she's
bringing that experience to us we always
are interested our starting Place always
is have other states done something that
we're interested in doing and if they
have we want to know about it we want to
build on it so that's we've looked at
other agendas that this group has done
in other states I mean all of that has
been part of the review process
follow up yeah
in more of the border states especially
up north Vermont Maine if they're coming
in practicing in New Hampshire do we
reach out to them for trainings it's a
great
um I believe we plan to we haven't yet
done that but it's a great question we
were going to we're actually meeting
next week I meet on a regular basis with
the woman from the National Association
of council for children and we're always
talking about how can we bring this to
more people we want to advertise in the
bar news so we want to go well beyond
the Outreach to the 70 plus great
suggestion thank you thank you
representative Macbeth thank you Mr
chairman it will be quick
um is there a fee cap on the um amount
of legal fees that these attorneys are
paid and what is the average hours that
these attorneys spend over the 12 months
thank you
great question there is a fee cap and
that is by Court rule that was recently
increased as far as the hourly rate so
that we are hoping is going to prompt
some more folks to be able to afford
really to do this type of work because
we haven't seen anyone yet really
getting rich with this type of work but
at least they can they're certainly very
good advocates for their clients I don't
think I can speak to the average that
the the average amount there whatever
the cap is often they're
pushing beyond that but they can't bill
for whatever they're pushing beyond that
so the rates are they have improved I
guess I will put it that way they have
improved and we and that just happened
last year so we've yet to necessarily
see the the needle move much but we're
hoping that there will be some new folks
coming in particularly as Christy said
trying to get this into the law school
law students to have them interested in
this type of important work
if I could just add the there is a cap
depending on the hearing type and and
we've worked very closely with the
judicial Council around that cap I think
for example uh it's five hours for the a
review hearing so it's not a lot of time
if you consider the prep work before the
hearing the work in the court hearing
itself
um so we were we've had a lot of
conversations with the judicial Council
around that
representative thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question would
you be able to provide us with you know
what those caps are and what the
financial cap I guess ends up being just
you know for example you mentioned that
there was a there was a five hour cap
further review hearing what does that
equate to financially
um you know I know for example when we
heard about the involuntary admission
ones it was 150 caps I'm just wondering
what what the financial amount is if you
know we can definitely provide you that
information and we'll get that over to
you thank you and with that thank you so
much we may be bringing you back if we
wake up in the middle of some night and
had a question we wish we thought of
when you were here we'll give you a call
you don't have to answer your phone in
the middle of the night however so thank
you for coming thank you for all the
so now it looks like we do not have
another presentation from an agency and
we can move right into pink card
questions and before we do a couple
little little business items there is no
meeting of this group next week
no meeting May 30. there will be a
meeting on the 6th of June under Vice
chairs leadership
I will be with Marissa hen from DHHS we
are Milbank fellows and we will be
having our cohort meeting in Seattle
on June 13th I think that's going to be
court day and we are slowly finding out
uh where and when and who and how and
can we come early to look around at
things and can we stay a little later
and ask some questions so um Miss Daya
will be keeping us up to date as she
knows these things
I will be leaving today at 11 30 as you
know the British Vice Count Council will
be speaking in reps Hall at noon and as
a graduate of a British University I've
been invited to meet with him ahead of
time so I will be ducking out at 11 30.
with that
in mind
none of you attest to being nickel
Melinda Nicolosi okay
then we will go with attorney Paula Umi
she's not in the room
that's okay she'll come back
and now for
um Donald it's either Gilbert or Gilbert
depending on where you're from
and he was Gilbert last week so I'm
gonna I'm gonna go out in the limb and
say it's Gilbert this week
and you know the rules of five minutes
and make it important so I did go ahead
and request 10 minutes upon that if I
could be proceeding with that but we'll
so good morning thank you for hearing
this testimony as such I've been here
prior and I'm here yet again
um
so you heard over the last few weeks uh
several instances you heard from
director rimsa from dcyf himself blame
the division for a lot of these
shortcomings in the Family Division A
lot of these delays and uh continuing
flaws of our courts
um simply a lot of constituents are
blaming the judges when reality is it is
um
we must get to practicalities specifics
thank you
so again the main issue here is that
takes up these courts hearings is 169 C
and chins and delinquencies for dcyf
as we heard already
dcyf attested to the fact that they are
continuously waiting on criminal
aspects on why they are delayed or why
169 C's or chins or delinquency is
delayed or one reason or another
as you also heard that the issue in my
own is post-conviction therapy that
cannot be afforded to me as you also
know there's a statutory obligation to
reunify or terminate within 12 months to
provide permanency for these children my
case has been going on for three and a
half years the mother in this case with
the child separated has been going on
dcyf has recently admitted they have no
grounds for termination with myself
there is no criminal aspect to my case
there never will be a criminal aspect to
this case that being said there is a
criminal aspect on the other end
moving forward back in 2020 May of 2020
to start this off dcyf originally did
not provide that the non-accused parent
um for one reason or another obviously
that was during covid it came to a point
where we exhausted all options for
placement of this child no foster homes
no residential placements were taking
children at the time so dcyf
inadvertently went ahead under 169 C
19e and conducted the custody hearing
for parents not charged
in that parents on the accused side and
Casa themselves are not allowed to
testify adverse information against the
parent the only purpose the only
prosecutor entity in those hearings for
those parents that to be found fit or
not fit is dcyf themselves and the
parent defending themselves no other
entity is allowed to testify adversely
against the parent
uh what dcy have failed to mention at
that permit at the uh hearing to Define
if the parent was fit or unfit was the
fact that back in 2015 one other child
nearly died in that household with
bleeding on the brain and a broken arm
what dcy have failed to mention is that
they closed out three open assessments
against the mother in attempts to place
that child into that home what dcy have
failed to mention to the court is that
they have 30 plus other allegations in
cases for abuse and neglect against the
mother with her other children what dcuf
failed to mention that we did not find
out until later on that the house was
infested with bed bugs roaches fecal
matter and urine are you running the
media
man I'm just it sounds like this is
testimony regarding one specific case
details without provide I mean
are we is this appropriate testimony I
guess is what I'm asking it sounds like
a disgruntled person talking about a
um
yeah I I imagine and I am sharing in the
absence of um of the chair
um I had not realized what he was doing
I think that the point that my colleague
makes is quite
um relevant
um we are not a trial court correct as
you know we also are not
um here uh in terms of assessing blame
or not on
dcyf understandable what we would like
to know is in your experience in the
family court
have you suggestions about changes in
procedure
based on your experience and can you
provide the documentation before the
points that you are trying to make that
is correct and that exactly what I was
getting at is the fact that Casa and
myself were not able to attest diet five
to those allegations that dcyf
themselves was failing to admit simply
because of kovid being an option and
they exhausted all options for placement
had Casa and I been able to attest to
that the child would not be harmed
so so moving forward with the
adjudicatory process so or let me back
up further for a second so obviously
with 169c 19e we need to revise that so
that adverse testimony may be provided
from Casa and the other party against
potentially uh parents not petitioned
moving towards to the adjudicatory
process in this case
we were not allowed to go forth and
have the CAC interviewed reviewed by the
judge under camera because of covid I'm
going to be a good guy and inform you
that although you have been at five
minutes you're going to get two and no
more
sounds good thank you so uh going
forward then we will go ahead and speed
this up quite a bit uh so during that
adjudatory process the judge did not
allow us to review the CAC
during that we do not know if the judge
or did not that's the only thing I can
blame upon the judge is that we should
have been allowed to review that CAC
interview
uh unfortunately we do not have grounds
for appeal uh based on that adjucatory
process the dispositional obviously is
for post-conviction therapy that is not
afforded because dcyf cannot find a
party that is uh providing
post-confiction therapy for individuals
that are not convicted uh under 169 C 31
Immunity Clause any party that testifies
is immune from Criminal liability and
civil liability
uh moving forward to 2021 the dcyf
removed the child from the mother for x
y and z
and allegations of criminal charges that
are still pending in criminal
investigations through this last two
years dcyf is continually attempt to try
to place the child back in against
objection of the judge against the
objection of Casa against objection of
all of the parties and providers for the
child these ongoing issues are still
there
so so realistically where we're at is
you know dcyf is not complying with 169
c31 dcyf's not complying with 169 c25
which is the confidentiality
um there's been a number of issues
within this case regarding that
and overall it has led to this child be
being re-victimized under the
supervision of dcyf
um and that's kind of where we're at
thank you however
this is about civil court this is not a
committee about dcyf correct so that
being said the judge has ordered dcyf to
walk one way or another and dcyf is
refusing to follow the judge's orders
okay that still may be off topic but it
is an important thing and we'll have to
figure out what do we do with that
information correct and anything you
will have my written
documentation regarding this very soon
appreciate that and 11 copies 10 for
each of us and one for the files thank
you so much
and the chair recognizes Stephanie house
could
actually thank you
um I didn't know if there's anyone here
from uh dcyf or from the judicial branch
that could respond to the CAC interviews
and um really Who has possession or
right to to those there was a lot
brought up I don't know if it's so
outside but it just was confusing so I'm
wondering if that could be clarified by
any one of those departments if they're
present no there was I'm not going to
allow that to go forward because again
it is off our topic our topic is really
the court the court made a ruling are
someone's beef is with that somebody
isn't following the Court's rulings and
that's a different topic perhaps for
another committee I don't want to pursue
that so I'll be interested in seeing
that Court ruling because I that doesn't
make sense to me thank you
that's fair I'd like to see that too the
good morning and thank you for your time
my name is Stephanie
go ahead
you look like you were about to say
something
I often look that way okay even when I'm
not but I will to given the chance
children's Law Center of New Hampshire
thank you you were going to say that yes
I was okay would you say that please yes
and the litigation director for the
children's Law Center of New Hampshire
which is a new legal services nonprofit
that was authorized to commence business
at the end of November last year by the
New Hampshire Supreme Court we provide
interdisciplinary representation of
children so we represent children who
are court involved in either delinquency
chins or abuse and neglect cases we also
represent them in matters involving
special education needs and other legal
needs that present themselves to the
child
and I hope you have handouts at some
point
um I we plan to come back to this this
special house committee and we will have
handouts at that time
um I'm here a bit unexpectedly because
our executive director I believe has
coveted so did not want to share that
with you so I've come in her stead
um so I come from that perspective and I
also come to speak with you from the
perspective of a former foster parent
and the current parent of an adopted
child that we adopted out of foster care
and one of the things that I wanted to
talk to the special committee about in
terms of the legal process in abuse and
neglect proceedings is that New
Hampshire is one of only 14 states that
don't provide children with lawyers in
abuse and neglect proceedings
and what the research has shown is that
children when they have legal
representation in abuse and neglect
proceedings they reach permanency faster
and their outcomes in general are much
better and that's why the National
Association of council for children is
working with
legislators in New Hampshire on passing
amended legislation to broaden the scope
of legal representation for children in
abuse and neglect cases I'm going to ask
you to clarify something you said 14
states do have this or don't have this
New Hampshire is one of only 14 who do
not offer counsel for children thank you
thank you
um
yes go ahead representative so you say
that the legislature has proposed
legislation on this
um
it's important
there is a committee that is considering
amending legislation to 169 C I think
it's 10 which has a very narrow
provision by which courts at the at the
moment can appoint counsel for children
um right now New Hampshire law is that
courts can only appoint counsel for
children when the child's expressed
interest the child or youths expressed
interest is contrary to the Casa's
determination of what is in the child's
best interests so if there's a conflict
there then Casa is instructed to inform
the court and the court can appoint
council at that time could you tell us
what the bill number is what the
committee is I mean where the end of
this session's legislative process and
perhaps I'm the only one on the
committee who isn't aware of this
would let me provide you that
information via email after today
to all of you yes thank you
um does Chris
yeah go ahead
the chair recognizes our esteemed
Stellar I'm giving you a chance to get
to a mic
be non-parallel non-parel
we did see a bill HB 535 in children and
family did come through
um on uh legal representation and I
don't know if this is a provision you're
speaking about you said hb10 I don't
know if that was added to it but I did
do research previously I can send to the
committee
the chair recognizes somebody from
children to family lot not being the
um thank you Mr chairman just to clarify
on this so I believe it's 5 35 and we've
retained it I think that the language
there was some issue with the language
so we're just working on that but it is
something that we're interested in thank
you and if I said hb10 I apologize I
think I meant 169 C10 which is the
current provision by which Council can
be appointed under those narrow
circumstances so as you look at us and
in your mind can tell who's on Judiciary
from who's on children and family law
you could seek out any of us or them who
are on children and family law if you
wish to input to us because we've kept
it and they kept it and they're going to
work on it right
thank you thank you and I'll just say
from my perspective as a foster parent
and adoptive parent when our child was
going through this process she happened
to have a was in agreement with what the
casa was recommending and the judge in
that particular case was very careful
also to hear from her and as the court
Improvement project indicated to you
earlier they have created protocols
about encouraging children to be present
at these hearings and to speak with the
judges in these hearings because that is
a benefit to the child it provides the
child a sense of agency in a process
where they feel like their life is in
somebody else's control and it is a
similar benefit when counsel is
appointed to represent the child's
actual interest that the child feels
like somebody is here fighting for me
for what I want the child feels like
they're they have some agency and
control over over their their experience
and I know from my own child's
experience that that was incredibly
valuable and we were very lucky to have
the players in the system that she had
she you know still sees the judge around
town and thinks of him as her judge
um and so that has been very valuable
for her and we just wish that more
children who were in this process in New
Hampshire could see the benefits there
another Point could we yes of course the
last uh the hearing that we heard talked
about there's only 70 family judges in
the state about
um
lawyers thank you parent attorneys
um about how many attorneys have
experienced representing children in
this sort of thing
roughly thank you for the question it's
a very good question we've been trying
to figure out how often attorneys get
appointed to represent children in abuse
and neglect cases and the number is
vanishingly small the next point that I
was going to make was that New Hampshire
has a lot of really great statutes that
protect children's rights in these
proceedings for children who also have
special education rights and needs there
are all sorts of statutes that bring in
special considerations there's the
foster child Bill of Rights which
establishes many important Rights for
kids in this situation
there are almost no New Hampshire
Supreme Court opinions interpreting
those statutes that protect the rights
of children in these cases because we
have not found a single New Hampshire
Supreme Court case that was brought on
behalf of a child in an abuse and
neglect proceeding and so these statutes
aren't well developed these statutes
aren't familiar to all of the players
because there isn't the kind of back and
forth about what the statute means and
when does it need to be applied because
the Supreme Court isn't being asked to
take a look at these particular statutes
that deal with the child's rights
because there's nobody in the courtroom
at the trial court level in the family
court that is advocating for these
particular statutes on behalf of the
child would it be your opinion that when
children and family law does a work
session on this retained Bill HB 535 it
would be helpful to have some of those
folks maybe somebody from
um
Circuit Court Family Division maybe from
the Supreme to weigh in on because I I
know that the courts asked the
legislature periodically hey give us
something and would it be your opinion
that in addition to yourself being there
a few members of the court system would
be helpful to the work we're doing I I
think so I think so again it's not that
the Supreme Court doesn't hear 169 C
cases there are two points of mandatory
appeal in that process but they are
points that are of significance to
parents and not necessarily of
significance to the children and the
rights that are protected by New
Hampshire law for the children and so
the the those statutes that are focused
on the child's rights don't often get
brought up and we're going to continue
with questions if there are any and do
we have any representative Smith
thank you very much you said that you uh
your organization was created by the
Supreme Court no New Hampshire has a
statute that if uh to create a legal
services
non-profit providing
um legal services to the Indigent the
New Hampshire Supreme Court has to
approve that agency and so we're an
independent non-profit agency but we
were approved to operate by the New
Hampshire Supreme Court in late November
of last year thank you very much can you
tell me where your funding comes from
right now our funding comes from private
donations exclusively exclusively at
this point yes thank you do you uh do
you recognize any um
overlap with the disabilities rights
Center
our founder Lisa Wolford who is the
executive director is a former Attorney
at disability rights Center and that's
an organization with whom we coordinate
quite a lot and speak quite a lot
disability rights Center
um
often represents children in special
education matters and so that's an area
in which we have overlap they don't
often represent children in abuse and
neglect proceedings thank you any other
questions
representative long
thank you thank you Mr chairman
the 36 states that have appointed
attorneys is there an age that's a
commonality
uh where
they would start appointing that's a
good question and I don't know the
breakdown of those 36 States but I
believe that that is
sometimes a common area where States
will say children or youth at a certain
age
shall be given counsel so some states do
do cut off things in terms of age and I
think I think that there is some
um
that makes sense because children have a
hard time expressing their own interests
and to an appoint an attorney to
represent them that that attorney would
be appointed to represent their
expressed interest and for children who
cannot express their their own interests
that would be a hard relationship to to
work through great thank you
and thank you for your testimony thank
you and the chair would like to ask the
researcher
um since we're going to be doing a 535
work session HB 535 have have I asked
you my usual question of what do the
yeah
okay
could you send me another one
and the chair recognizes The Honorable
Dan it's uh
an alumnus of Children and Family Law
many many terms on that body right
merely eight merely eight
uh thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee
um I'm honored and pleased to be here
for the record I'm Dan Itza and uh my
residence is in Manchester currently
um
I want since the issue is one of Court
procedure and adherence to the law
I'm going to take to the liberty of
speaking to you about a case which I
know intimately uh some of you may also
know but I'm going to refrain from using
any names
uh
there is a member of your body
who was accused of
abuse neglect in regard to medical
treatment
dcyf got involved
and in the proceedings of the case
they violated statute repeatedly
uh first of all they failed to meet
statutory deadlines
for when the permanency you know for the
uh after the ex parte hearing you have a
your your first hearing that was not
held within the statutory requirement
other statutory deadlines for subsequent
hearings were also missed
were reasons given
um
no not to the best of my knowledge and I
was in Intimate discussion yes
yeah well no I well okay I know yes
uh you said they is this DC dcyf or is
this the court the court actually failed
to meet the failed to schedule within
period required by Statute
I suspect that is due to a lack of
adequate number of judges
and I for one am an advocate for there
being more judges
as strange as that may seem
um I think it would
the reason that there is a state of New
Hampshire is to punish Injustice and to
provide Equity better than the people
could themselves if there were no
government and to the degree that
you as a government fail to do so
um you failed your first purpose and if
if more judges are required to achieve
Justice then more are required
um and I would well
different topic but in 2006 I was uh
pleased to achieve my first passage of
legislation
and it was uh to require that in dcyf
hearings that all evidence be submitted
five days before the hearing so that
there was adequate time for discovery
the court failed to enforce that
and in this particular case they were in
fact
reams of data transmitted to the defense
obviously the ability to even see if
this was relevant material was
inadequate
now this isn't a this isn't a sore loser
complaint because in fact
they won the case
and and the judge in the end said this
is a wonderful family this should never
have happened
so even the judge
him or herself attested to yes and
there's a matter of the court record
but the problem is is that the the judge
in the process did not enforce the
statute upon dcyf and make sure that the
defense had adequate discovery now one
of the reasons in in in
respect to the previous speaker
the family made the effort and expense
of
uh obtaining independent legal counsel
and I think that was probably key in the
and I think he would the the individ the
the uh
parent
uh
would be inclined to introduce
legislation to that effect that such
should be the norm and available
and that there should be a stated
opportunity for the for the family to
obtain
legal counsel for the child
that that is
you know the child is after all an
interested party in this
if there's really harm then the child
needs to be protected if it's a spurious
case the child needs to be protected
from the state question from the vice
chair yes
hello Representatives good to see you
um
who were you proposing uh pay for the
legal counsel provided for the child if
the family can in this case the family
could I think that would fall to the
family but if the family is Indigent and
unable to then uh just as we have uh
constitutional right to protection in
criminal cases I think uh in the case of
a holy innocent party there's an
obligation there
but on the part of the state
or private contributions whatever
I'll give you a couple more minutes
because I interrupted you during the
five no
um
I just want to
encourage I'm going to tell you one
thing that happened to me very recently
and this and this is really why you are
here
the given the frequency of divorce
virtually everyone in this state
has been before the family court or
knows someone who has been before the
family court
and therefore the family court is the
face of the Judiciary in New Hampshire
the people's opinion of the family court
is there a opinion of the Judiciary as a
whole
and at its foundation this is all about
preserving the reputation and honor of
having just returned from wintering in
South Carolina I took the opportunity to
go back to my town of Fremont to get my
car inspected and my truck and uh
as I was there I met one of my former
constituents who was also getting his
truck inspected
and
I introduced myself and then he thanked
me for having been his representative
and and I said well you know I'm still
involved and this is what I'm going to
do tomorrow be here before you today
and I mentioned the subject matter of
the committee being the review of the
the family court
and
his immediate response like word
association response
was they're messed up
would he be willing to come and give
specific issue I have not a clue I I he
was just a former constituent that was
that was a public reaction to the state
much appreciated
but it underscores what we know and
thank you for your testimony and welcome
back to cold New Hampshire it's good to
be back where the roads are flat
and I hope you land in the district and
run again we miss you in the house
I miss being here immensely
hello and remember on point
specific thank you got it
uh and and thank you honorable committee
and chairman Pearson for what you're
attempting here I have complete respect
and I really appreciate the fact that
that's why you guys have gathered and I
believe you all have the best of
intentions flattery and expressions of
appreciation do not count against your
my name is Ed Bryants I'm from the
Cheshire county I live in Marlboro New
Hampshire
um
my testimony may be a little different
because I have a functioning and best
interest co-parenting Arrangement that
I've had for almost 10 years now my
family court experience goes back 10
years when a Judicial decision was
rendered with a favorable outcome I'll
touch briefly on a few key failures I
experienced and will ask the committee
to have me expand on a few points if if
it's of any interest I'd also like to
ask this committee to respect the fact
that I have a mutually respectable
co-parenting relationship and absolutely
do not wish to open any Old Wounds or
rehash hold conflicts I respect my
co-parent too much appreciate that give
us a few specific negatives that we can
consider I like to use my own and just
to give you guys a little reference I'm
the chairman of the New Hampshire for
equal shared parenting division it's a
national effort I've worked with time to
put kids first we've created a
I'm sorry it's a
co-parenting seminar as a tool for the
judicial system to use when parents file
for divorce or custody it basically
teaches them to make your kids the first
priority not disrespect your ex
um
I also work uh I'm a board member on the
MPS board for peer support I run a
co-parenting collaborative group to
myself and a female that we meet weekly
and have people going through mental
health issues because of dealing with
the family court system and it gives
them a relief
my first distinct point is with Guardian
items I believe we all can agree
Guardian items are the ears and eyes of
the Court their job is to look at
conflict in my opinion look for any
dangers that would deem apparent unfit
and unable to safely parent their child
my Guardian guardian litem and I from
the start had an unproductive
relationship I was likely conflict of
personalities but I was completely aware
of her recommendations would weigh heavy
in a judge's decisions I was ordered to
pay half of an initial thousand dollar
fee and then was met with several
motions for the the gal limit to to
increase the limit I was not being heard
and often was hung up when trying to
attempt her and my only recourse to
reply with a motion to deny the
increases as a pro se litigant
I would ask for not
sorry but Char I would ask the judge to
charge the jail for theft of services
because she was not doing her assigned
job in retaliation the guardian litem
would turn her reports more and more
negative towards me
um in my place of worship I found an
unsigned ex parte motion stamped with
the law office that my my ax had
retained it was a joint motion by the
petitioner in the guardian ad litem in
other words the guardian litem as a
mutual third party should never have
been a party to a joint motion so that's
one of the points I'd like to point out
um
after four administrative delays and at
a full evidential hearing it was the
ex-party motion had to do with they
considered me to be a flight risk that
was the eminent danger that was
presented to the court at my full
evidentiary hearing almost two years
later it was revealed the Flight Risk
came about from a Facebook post to my
father who had been diagnosed with stage
four lung cancer he lived in Virginia
and I simply expressed that I would love
for him to meet his granddaughter
that took my child from me for two years
uh visitations I'll skip that the
Advocacy Center I went to after being
assaulted by my co-parent before it was
ex-wife refused me assistance but
through that program in adnoc Center for
violence prevention they then
recommended and provided the other party
with a lawyer or helped them get a
lawyer it was at that time
that
the legal legal expert this is one of my
garden when my child time was you get
that 30 seconds okay
uh
basically
the probably most important point is
during the time as I was getting visits
with my child they were not being met by
the other party and contacting the
police to help enforce Force the written
court orders uh the police would often
say that this is a civil matter go to
court file a contempt charge those were
never dealt with that part needs to be
strengthened I have a Texas statute that
was just passed that deals with that
I'll hand it into you guys so it's sort
of a template okay to address what I was
hoping to bring does anybody have any
questions uh yes uh counselor go ahead
representative Macbeth thank you for
allowing me to ask a question
um thank you for taking it in your
materials that you're passing in do you
have a copy of the Facebook post which
you said you just said I'd love for my
child to meet you and based on that the
court took away or your child children
were taken away from you for two years
just so do you have that Facebook post
and that court order I could probably
get it for this cases 10 years old
um thank you for your question and I and
I respect that that caught your
attention I just recently last year had
five large storage totes of all my court
litigation and I had a bonfire I was
happy to get rid of it I'm sure it's
still court record and if that was
important for you and you'd like to see
it I could I could get that for you
documentations of things are important
uh people say do you not trust me that's
not the issue we want to so be able to
verify what you say that when we draw
conclusions it is because we are
convinced absolutely so and I would also
suggest to you and to representative
it's a uh on the specific uh court case
you mentioned that you provide to the
front the specifics that way we can
check it out some of us are familiar
even better thank you and and to you
Miss Mr
um uh Brian's uh if if you could get the
information of that specific case where
the allegation of uh impropriety on the
courts again we want to verify yes okay
I appreciate it and it's frankly it was
in a broader range for you folks to uh I
see the same thing repeated often
because I deal with a lot of family
court and if you know a few people who
are willing to testify and provide
specific things about their case and not
generalizations about other things or
people would be happy to hear them going
forward we're going to be meeting June 6
20 and 27. and again I appreciate what
you guys are doing and that's fluff
after I've talked got it thank you and
I'm going to give one more shot to
Melinda Nicolosi from Cambridge Mass
traffic is bad coming north I know but
not here okay and now uh chair
recognizes Paula wermi you've asked to
speak so this is your chance
I do not Paula you are recognized for
five minutes we mean it
give it your best shot thank you sir I
didn't even bring up my notes
um
and actually I didn't have a lot of oral
testimony today why is it specific to
the point yes I wanted to highlight that
dcyf court records
are not considered dcyf records under
the statute and parents can submit them
I think most parents would prefer to
redact their child's name
and certainly I've tried not to give you
uh children's names or even ligands
names in
written materials I've given you these
people don't know me and I don't wish to
out them
to the committee unnecessarily
um
also with respect to
what uh representative Itza said
was
um I'm also familiar with that case
and I'm familiar with the fact that
there was no preliminary hearing because
the judge ended the hearing
when dcyf was finished with their
presentation
um
I don't know the specifics of what was
said because that's the one thing he
couldn't tell me I think for a fact you
gave us a fact
that the hearing was ended abruptly okay
we'll check that out too
please but he can't he can't legally
give you a transcript you've made that
illegal
so it's got to be his testimony I think
we'll worry about that okay
um
and also
I think some of the speakers here today
have been excellent they've given me
ideas for future written testimony
um councilor that's not important okay
say specifics of a case to us or you are
wasting our time
okay
um the specifics of the cases are in my
written testimony
this is one copy
I'm sorry I I'm in a living situation
where I can't I don't even have room for
a printer and I'm paying for all those
copies give you a question is this one
copy ten copies that you didn't staple
one copy one copy thank you
um
and I I also figured out that I can get
the committee copies of even old
testimony
um toward the end by putting them on
thumb drives if you're interested
that'll make it easier for everybody to
see and it'll actually be cheaper than
paper
um
so with that
thank you for the two-week break I will
Endeavor to submit testimony
more in a fashion
that you can file it in categories in
the future
um
and I'm certain I'll be back in two
weeks
if you attest that you will give us
specific details with specific
objections in specific cases and not
side bunny Trails I will call on you
again okay
I've had some medical issues this week
and I didn't get to the oral testimony I
would have endeavored to do that you
should have pulled your pink cards
because you have basically wasted our
time
yes I'm sorry Mr chair but when someone
comes to testify
for many people even if they're
experienced it's traumatic and I think
um
to challenge
them and I I hope we can keep a slightly
higher level
and Madam Vice chair if this person in
question were not an attorney
and had not agreed to testify with
useful information
for the first time and went off on a
sidebar
I would have responded differently
the chair recognizes Vivian Gerard Mr
chair
do you have a question
my question really is about
expectations of some of the witnesses I
noticed that that pile of paper is at
least 50 if not a hundred pages and I
didn't see that it was delineated or hot
I mean
I don't think the expectation of the
committee is that we are going to be
able to read documents like that that
are not don't have specific
you know a table of contents that tell
us what concerns so I I don't know I
know I'd ask you earlier when we were
going to get the documentation because
for me my memory isn't so good I kind of
need to get what they're giving us then
and also I'm concerned about getting
that much information in two or three
weeks and then not remembering what the
testimony was it it isn't as beneficial
sure would like to ask a member of the
committee to skim through it and if it
to the degree and where it contains
specific things about specific cases
that we will then can consider as we
make recommendations we'll keep that
the part of it that is not relevant to
us
will still keep but will flag
accordingly so that when we go to read
through things we will be reading
through the things that are important to
us lest we miss some of them for being
bogged down in things that are not
relevant so I I was going to ask this
later but I'll ask it now is there
somebody would like to take a quick read
through that and do the relevant versus
other matters delineation
it looks like sheep
I'm sorry
yeah thank you Mr chairman it looks like
she did give specific topics in here and
then she also gave printouts of examples
of the things that she was suggesting or
alleging were issues so I I think she
just provided a lot of information in
here but she did provide like some
covers over the different things as I'm
looking I believe correct me if I'm I'm
wrong attorney worm it looks like that
you provided some specific things that
you thought should be changed or were
problems and then you provided examples
of them and and some case studies
to the degree that is true then you
clerks can go through it and separate
them by the specific topics and somehow
get them into the relevant folders for
consideration and it looks like there's
a lot more wheat and a lot less chat the
chaff than I feared so thank you and
thank you for doing that
the poster child of copies you've come
to my other committee well armed with
printouts in multiple colors sometimes
we will not hold that against you good
um thank you chairman and members of the
chair committee
um I'd like to thank the judge Ashley
that came in earlier because she
actually proved my point these agencies
come into you today and tell you what
they're paid to be telling you they're
not telling you reality of what happens
in the real world and they just tell you
to go get an attorney and I feel like
she was specifically painting myself
even as this pitcher and making you feel
and look like an abuser to lose your
children and as I had provided to the
committee in the past and it's actually
in the packet that you have right there
I have proved that the judges were
biased and they were disparaging me in
my case the the transcripts were
modified there was false DVS false dcyf
reports false police reports that proved
harassment just in that JCC
report that I gave you which is page two
you will see that these judges allowed
constant harassment in my case
um even though I went to the Supreme
Court on five appeals
um you got a different outcome depending
on different judges
and as we all know we've had a series of
bad judges in our in our system but the
fact that if if any one of us had child
support and it went to the Appeals
who is child support who who in child
support allows
your case to be put on hold when you're
supposed to be getting monthly child
support obligations and I'm not the only
one in that package I believe it's a
last page I gave you Genevieve Ward's
child support obligations as well as
myself both of you have done this with
her permission absolutely okay and as
you can see that only goes up to 2022
and she has at to this day over a
hundred thousand dollars in arrears I
was very lucky I had Judge Karen that
was amazing trying to make use of my
case because of the way it's come out to
fix these things but bcss has different
categories whether you're a title four
the the what they don't tell you is not
every case is an enforcement case that
some cases end up being a collection
agency and they pictured me as a
non-title 4 case which again you don't
know these things until you don't know
them and to interrupt here
um you're giving us broader statements
but the documentation is here yes it
will say where when what how who that we
like better than that okay I emailed you
it's I believe it was a 15 page document
last week after our last hearing that
said facts and background which was
every single date every single situation
and who the judges were on that
particular document it's about four
inches
of actual backup information and I only
have a small amount with me that I just
presented to judge king recently so
everything that I tell you is true and I
have a document that backs everything up
that's the secret word and I gave you
every document
um listed on that facts and background
but if you want further I could
certainly provide it but what I would
what I'd like to um
funnel back to is with child support
they treat people as a collection agency
and not everybody knows that and if
you're not considered a title IV they do
not do any enforcement whatsoever and in
my case
I got the letters of wage assignments
being supposedly taken I got the
enforcement letters and all of that was
provided to you with dates and Who
provided it
the problem is if you have this Melissa
Pence and Mesa which is their legal
department this woman put my case on
hold just as she did Genevieve Ward and
Genevieve Ward cannot take the time to
come in here today but our cases are so
very close because they
change the court orders they put the
cases on hold and it appears that they
have more power than these judges have
do they provide reasons for putting them
on hold yeah they told me that because I
my case was in appeals which I've been
in the court system for nine years so
that just tells you where my child
support has been on hold for nine years
and the fact that they're the change in
these orders around and on my case which
I gave you they come up with these these
positive balances and with no
explanation so that it looks like you
got all these credits on your account
and when you challenge that you ask for
an audit you ask for a supervisory
review you asked for the judicial
hearings and I even asked for a right to
know which I also gave to you that was
in March I've been asking for this since
2016. there is no procedure for while
something's under repeal the money to be
paid into an escrow account no no they
just stop everything all together and
whatever was the previous one that
nobody argued on and in my case it was
in the amount of 533 dollars so in 2021
it's changed many times along the way
but 2021 is when we finally got it to
the point that my case law wasn't too
much it was into effect but the point
being here is even like when I request
the right to know the process I used
from Mount ruthia which you'll have his
testimony as well he got his information
I didn't get mine but it just seems
weird because bcss says they have no
interest in these cases and I just don't
see anything that's consistent I don't
see that what they're telling us is true
to their word okay good thank you thank
you thank you now a couple things um
first of all uh Ms Ward you referenced
who couldn't be here could she send us a
one or two pager with her specific case
so it's the same kind of deal but with
the specifics listed so that we could
put that in the folder and secondly uh
I want to compliment you this is usable
information this is
um stuff that's going in the folder to
be considered when we look at specific
thank you
chair recognizes uh Randall Collier from
sorry
to come on up if that's you
to the last person on the end you know
if this was a quiz show I'd say come on
down but you may address the group
you're going to turn need to turn the
good morning special committee thank you
for hearing me Randall Collier from Keen
um just want to give you an update uh
from my common law Rita Satori that I
submitted to Supreme Court
um last month they actually denied
um the appeal
for the false allegations of domestic
violence and that was the paper that I
gave you and I was a uh the Supreme
Court rules for extensions for
reconsideration to file the appeal uh
Supreme Court said it was discretionary
because it wasn't within the 30-day
window however it had all questions of
law in it
um and I was just curious like I'm not
really familiar with the dcyf part but
if the if the judge takes the kids away
from the dcyf for abuse
does that go to a criminal court or does
that stay in the equity court if anybody
has an answer to that later on and I'm
not sure
um but if it is Criminal Court then why
is it separated when they separate
parents in equity Court without abuse
that's a good question to find out
and I just wanted to give you the
to to
um dovetail on on that question I wonder
sometimes too because
uh when you start making some serious
accusations against somebody uh
that can slop over into a criminal
complaint and yet
the rules are still family I mean
there's a gray area there that needs to
be addressed in my opinion but that's
just me okay Madam Vice chair it's all
yours
here
good morning Madam Vice chair
I just wanted to follow up with a very
positive suggestion that I heard last
time from Miss bartello
involving uh offering more support staff
to judges possibly in the form of
clerk's paralegals and not what and what
not
in support of that very positive
suggestion I'd like to offer a specific
case slice
as to why I believe that's
uh
really necessary
you've heard testimony from Miss Silva
about a wonderful jurist
uh I've sat through many hearings
presided over
uh by that officer and I think he does a
wonderful job but in my case he was
simply overworked
and
the issue I'm raising is a very poor
order from an otherwise very good judge
quite specifically on December 18 2020
which is a Friday
the other party filed a motion for an
extension of a protective order it was
not even marked ex parte
and by Monday morning that was sort of
rubber stamped and granted
certainly I have a remedy on appeal and
you know was able to get a positive
order out of our Supreme Court
regarding that
but I would respectfully suggest
go through all of that just having some
more resources where he had time to
actually read that where he had time to
hear from both sides
where there was time to really figure it
out
uh
before it went up on appeal might have
been a much more cost effective
and better remedy
and I would also remark uh begin with
regard to this jurist
um
before the
Joint Committee where chief justice
McDonald gave his presentation uh you
also heard testimony from Miss ortolano
in which she won her case before you
know this judge yet filed a complaint
anyway simply because it took so long
and
you know that's just there to support
these good people really need the
resources they need to get it right at
the trial court level
so that an appellate court doesn't have
um and I think that's about all I have
to say on that I can get you a copy of
that specific order again December
Friday
December 18 2020 granted Monday
December 21st 2020 without any input
from the other side and to this day I
still don't even know the reason it was
granted there was no narrative it just
says granted and whereas the statute
says the court shall state in writing
you know it's reasons or reasons and we
never got that in its two and a half
years later
and again
you know it's about overwork I think on
this order not about
any sort of malfeasance on the part of
the the judicial officer
with that said I'll take any questions
thank you very much are there any
questions from my colleagues
yes representative law uh thank you
madam chair uh
the uh well you referenced the 12 2020
and the granted on the 21st uh did you I
I thought I saw something
um familiar to that that you had already
submitted with us was that already
submitted to us uh no that's not
something I've submitted
this is separate I'll need to submitted
and it's essentially a specific slice to
really support Miss partello's testimony
from the last hearing all right thank
you
thank you are there any other questions
thank you again for being here Mr Oliver
thank you the chair recognizes Robert
tangway
excuse me you just turned the mic off
I thought I understood what was going on
uh thank you madam uh Vice chair I
believe Smith
um my name is Robert Tanguay I have uh
I would like to thank you all for being
here this is very important
um I have a two-pronged testimony one is
going to be about my personal experience
uh in my life growing up as a fatherless
child and the second will be my
experience with the court system now how
they are not following rules I've been
looking up the specific statutes
um I I respect
your the importance of of your own life
experience but here we need to focus
exclusively on the Family Court
right
so and I understand
um Madam uh and I believe that does is
relevant um in uh
reference to Mr albrecht's testimony I
believe it's kind of the 14th article of
the New Hampshire Constitution articles
I mean uh remedies are to be free prompt
and without denial so basically what's
happening is the court is overworking
and you will find that this is for
specifically at Pro Se individuals and
so that's something that we need to uh
work into I'm going to ask the uh this
group to actually have me come and speak
for a period of time 30 minutes which I
will provide actual facts and a report
and I will do that in writing so uh
specifically to answer uh Madam chair
Smith
um
what we have
is I looked up 173b and the court has
issued orders specifically that are in
violation of 173 B Section 3 and the
opposing part a council who never even
filed an appearance in either case which
recommended that I use our family wizard
which would violate
the protection order and if you look at
section three it says if either party
Wishes the defendant to be excused from
any provision of an order of protection
the remedy is to petition the court for
modification modification of such order
specifically so that a court can't give
out another order they must modify the
order which is sent to the police and by
the way I did not commit domestic
violence
um so
there are many such orders uh things
that have happened and I can provide the
specifics everything I say I can back up
in paperwork writing it's with the
courts they're just brushing us aside
um
so myself in relation to today's
testimony I
my mother left my father when I was one
month old I did not meet him until I was
14 years old he died when I was 18. I
had no relationship with him
uh
I worked down the street at Radio Shack
in Concord when there was Radio Shack on
Main Street I know the state I know this
this world and and the pain that I went
through not having a father
is the most important
I mean it's just it's so hard I had all
the ways that I would present that
testimony and I've cried by myself
um but it's
we have everybody who's testifying they
want to be part of their children's
lives and they have they do not want to
be here no one wants to be in court no
one wants to be here and that's why I
honor you for doing the job that you're
doing
um but there've been
besieged by a
profiteering type of business that is
everybody does what is in their own
perceived best interest and when women
or fathers It's usually the person with
the better family that gets the children
whoever can demonstrate that they have
the most money legal resources and I've
seen it could you provide documentation
for that please
uh yes I could I could we could do a
study and it would be something no no we
you know there was a president
a number of years ago who had a very
good
um
rubric which he operated under he said
trust but verify we need to verify what
we need from you understanding that each
of us you and and each of us have had
our own life experiences and they color
how we see things we understand that and
it's important and in no way am I
minimizing it but here we are looking at
how the family court functions and we
need to know
not what your life experience was not
what your predisposition is but just the
facts we need the facts that show us
where the court is doing a good job and
where the court is not doing a good job
where we could do something
to correct those problems and I
understand that um so I made several
recommendations and I would that's why I
do ask that I am given more time to
present such as the lobbyist that
presented last week for the uh domestic
violence uh Lobby
um she was a lobbyist and she said stuff
I believe people are actually trying to
do things but I have everything uh that
I'm saying to back up there are studies
and in my own experience and filings
with the court I have created a record
which verifies such but I can understand
how we need actual facts
um and the court is being presented with
such facts and you'll see
that when they're presented with such
facts they don't know the law they
violate the law and do so at the expense
of pro se litigants because they can get
away with it could you show us the
documentation please certainly
yes
thank you madam chair
um just a clarification
and thank you for taking the question
Christmas I thought I heard you say
something that the um
that the court ordered you to follow an
order but was that in violation of a
restraining order I'm not I missed
something somewhere yes
um it was in violation of the protective
orders they and they've actually held me
in contempt there's an order of contempt
for not filing and I filed multiple
papers saying hey this is
I can't do this so we're just a
clarification certainly so were they
asking you to use a a communication
app to have direct communication with
the protected party without changing the
order and then I did send a motion
objection
and I have the index numbers too so I
have all the index numbers and so
yes thank you for that clarification
thank you Miss Paul
no
okay no no
um five minutes I have I actually have a
book it's called incentives in the
environment and basically the end and
it's published and registered in the
Library of Congress and um that can be
given as testimony too and what I've
determined is that people do what's in
their perceived best interests so what
I'd like to back up is that people are
doing what's in their perceived best
interest by bullying people who have
less resources which isn't a violation
of 461a which was made in 2005
by this body and has sustained I don't
think that the laws per se need to be
changed they're just not being followed
thank you thank you very much for that
clarification I appreciate you taking
the time yet again to be here
um uh the the chair
rep recognizes
Vivian
well
why don't you come and and just sit
there
thank you uh members of the committee
um and I'm not going to say this as well
as Dave but he's not a very good public
speaker so I'm back on May 9th in 2013
Dave was actually a victim of a domestic
violence
um he did have some of the judges that
we've all experienced over here
um and he can obviously verify um if I
misspeak here but he in his case
um he was brought in as a defense
on his domestic violence and the judge
actually was trying to find abuse where
there was none
and unfortunately as we all know that
once you are classified as this painted
picture you lose everything and
unfortunately with Dave he
lost all of his property he lost his
rights he lost all everything that he
owned he he was in a situation that he
had to sign over his property and
unfortunately
um he he feels like his constitutional
rights were lost at the very beginning
and as everybody can tell you that once
you're a domestic domestic violence
victim whether you man a woman is one
quick phone call and your rights your
everything that you've ever lived for is
gone it's changed could you help me just
clarify when you say
a domestic
abuse victim
do you mean that he experienced abuse or
that he is a victim in your perception
or his position a victim of the system
so if I may try to clarify that so I was
in a unique situation and I appreciate
uh what representative ball said a few
weeks back
um there are guys who are victims of
domestic violence I was actually
assaulted by my ex-wife who's larger
than I am
um and she was able to craft a uh and I
I did nothing I walked away I'm a man
I'm not going to complain about it as
many guys do so I walked away not
knowing that I was going to become the
moving party in which the moving party
pays
and
she was able to then file a 173 B
against me
um
which put me in in a complete defensive
position I had a home-based business at
the time and these statutes essentially
pulled me out of that away from the kids
away from the business it shuttered my
business completely and put me on the
receiving end of of everything and not
even being able to
um
go through a divorce I was in survival
mode the entire time
and when we had our first domestic
violence hearing
uh
my ex-wife uh couldn't come up with a
good story uh judging Picasso asked her
you know where's the abuse I need the
abuse and she expressed that she
couldn't remember what Bridges had told
her to say
so then judge and decasso at the well
after our allowed 30 minutes
um
demanded that she have an example of
abuse and they did a little sidebar and
her attorney said that I sat on her
eight months ago and and judgment
Picasso said well there it is
and and that was it I was I was done it
was a good old school Mafia Shakedown
from that point on thank you very much
for that and you do speak quite clearly
and well so I don't think you have to
apologize to that and um could uh
it's my understanding that the judge
um is no longer on the bench and that he
the judge was removed for um cause and
that therefore at least in this
particular case in the cases involving
that judge
the system
the system worked although it did not
necessarily work to your person after I
had been steamrolled the system did work
however I have no uh remedy to recover
anything that I lost
um and and it's it's just uh you know
it's telling that when you go in as a
pro se
um you know I I know on on the orders at
the bottom it gives you your notice of
appellant Rights I would like to see a
whole form or or two pages of a form
which tells you all the other things I
didn't know about JCC complaints I was
one of so I'm from 2013. and I was I
think I'm one of the earliest ones in
our group to have complained against
Julian dracasso uh and Marigold Master
Del pra who said I don't care how your
kids live I had hearings where I was
brought in on EX parte's
self-represented with her well-financed
attorneys and I wasn't allowed to speak
and the marital Masa Del Prado would
drop his glasses to the end of his nose
and look at me
and the entire hearing went without me
saying a word thank you and what
happened to the marital Master he has
been removed as well thank you very much
I
anyone else have any
questions
um Mr Smith we share the last name thank
you no relationship they're very they're
very few of us of course
um thank you very much for being here
your suggestion that there ought to be
more detailed and clear discussion about
the possibility for what happens next
including uh appeal Alternatives is
something that I think the committee
would consider a very helpful suggestion
so thank you for being here thank you
for your time and I'm going to give you
um that exhausts the pin cards that we
have today is there anyone here who has
not submitted a pink art who has not
spoken but would like to speak to the
committee now
um
thank you for the opportunity my name is
Gail drobat from Amherst New Hampshire
these are from where Amherst New
Hampshire okay
um just a few of the laws 633 4 is
interference with child custody
and if you read that
um I don't know if any of you guys have
read this before but
it's a criminal code in every state
when a parent goes
to get relief
when a parent is interfering with child
custody they're told to go back to
family court it's a civil matter
it is a criminal code we need codes
enforced in this state this would
relieve the courts of being overburdened
with these issues
and it protects children it protects
children to have a right with both
parents so
that code needs to be enforced whether
law enforcement needs retraining on that
I'm not sure what the remedy is but
we need to look into that if possible
and the next page is Guardian ad litems
if you see 461 a16 regarding Garnier
enlightens
2019 January 1st they changed the laws
Guardian ad items are no longer to make
recommendations to judges
it shows bias and
we heard the guardian of the light and
board speak a few weeks back and he said
he kept repeating
the Guardians make recommendations it's
in the law if you go in you get court
orders
they always say with the guardian's
recommendations it's against New
Hampshire law they cannot do that
so again we need enforcement of these
things we've had several parents testify
about fees for Guardian Med items
they're paying ten thousand dollars the
guardian of litems are allowed since
23 hours to do their investigation
how are they making ten thousand dollars
in 23 hours
so
if we can
could you just give me the citation for
that 23 hours yes it is 461 a
six um 461 a 16 4 or 5.
4B
they have an hourly rate a maximum fee
for the appointment that will be
the hourly rate
will be no more than twice the fund of a
state funded case which we don't do
anymore but I think that fee was ninety
dollars the last time I heard so
um
unless the parties agree they can't go
over 23 hours and then if you go down to
five It also says they can't exceed
their fee cap
or provide services without prior
approval from the court after a hearing
I noticed that um
this printout does not come from the RSA
or
um or the the supplement has this been
changed since the um
the state uh
I don't understand your question
um representative Mitzi
men clarify that statute has not been
changed
the purpose was to show the state no
longer fund tal the purpose was to limit
J gal to the uh same extent that
state-funded Gio if they existed would
be funded wait and that it could not it
could not go beyond that without
agreement of parties and a confirmation
by the judge and that if they did so
so this is the 2018
Amendment thank you very much for that
clarification
so
in particular cases I know that's not
happening they're exceeding their fees
without hearings I know a specific and I
will provide you the information for
this I don't have it today but she was
suspended and terminated and continued
to work in the party's had to pay so
there needs to be oversight somewhere
there was a complaint to the gal board
they found no wrongdoing and I'm going
to present all that to you as well so
I'll save that for another day thank you
very much thank you thank you
um
yes I'm sorry representative
thank you
um it's not really a question but if you
wouldn't mind filling out a pink card
now just so we have it for record thank
okay not uh seeing anyone else
um I'd like to remind everyone that this
committee will not be meeting next
Tuesday we will meet again on June 6th
at 9 30 in this room